hi so my name is Jim I'm CEO of hops
works and associate professor at kth in
Stockholm I'm going to talk about how we
get data from The Lakehouse to python
using in particular Apache arrow and I'm
going to start by talking about data
processing at scale and there's
different scales you can see I have a
diagram here with different data
processing Technologies so we have um
smaller scale on the left hand side so
pandas might be considered a small scale
data processing tool and polers can
scale to larger volumes of data and
typically when people have very large
volumes of data they move to using tools
like uh a patchy spark or maybe a a data
warehouse in the cloud and DBT so it may
be big query or snowflake uh these scale
tools can handle you know they can scale
to process terabytes or pedabytes of
data H is batch applications and of
course you have real time we're not
going to cover real time today you have
tools like bite wax for Python and then
when you move to scale you might use to
Flink or beam or spark so what's
interesting here uh particularly for the
python Community is that you can see
you've got python tools on the leftand
side and everything on the right is
considered not python so we think of
distributed data processing on the right
hand side and and single host uh
processing on the left but what we see
now with increasingly large uh compute
so you can get virtual machines with 32
64 CPUs and and a lot of memory so
hundreds of gigabytes of memory um
there's an increase ing possibility for
doing data processing um at reasonable
scale so what we can see here is that
you know the data warehouses say well we
do both small scale and large scale and
python is is the provision of of small
scale but python does this kind of
little area here this is what we we
might call single machine workloads and
as single machines are getting larger
and larger and increasingly large volume
of uh workloads become possible in
Python and uh that hopefully will make
it easier for people to do data
processing in in in Python at reasonable
scale now one of the challenges with
this is that a lot of the Enterprise
data is increasingly be stored in what
are what is called The Lakehouse so
Lakehouse is really column or data
stored in object storage using a table
format like Delta Lake Apache hoodie or
Apache Iceberg they're the three
dominant table formats so what those
table formats give to Apache Park files
are ask updates um they give you
incremental updates H you can delete
data so you can be compliant with a lot
of Enterprise requirements um and they
also provide indexing as well so that
you can get faster access to your data
so this is great and they're um becoming
widely adopted so large volumes of
Enterprise data are being stored in the
Lakehouse and the tools that are being
used to write the data like spark or
Flink uh are obviously very scalable and
the first users of the lake housee are
primarily business intelligence tools so
we have query engines that scale to
massive volume so everything from
Snowflake using um Iceberg to datab
Bricks using Delta Lake to trino using
hoodi we have all these different query
engines that can access the data so how
does python get the data from Lakehouse
well most of the existing uh interfaces
for python to The Lakehouse are via jdbc
or obbc uh services so these kind of
servers are a bottleneck because the
data in The Lakehouse is stored in
columnar format and these are row
oriented form formats so the data will
have to be pivoted from column oriented
to row oriented and back again so the
question is is can we get to the data in
The Lakehouse more efficiently and
faster from python so that we can work
with this data in pandas or polers and
uh we'll talk about that in the course
of this talk and we're going to talk in
particular about using aaty arrow and a
query engine. DB to get faster access to
lcas data for python
clients
so if business intelligence is is
primarily the main consumer of data um
from The Lakehouse at the moment where
is the burning need for lak house data
in Python workloads so we don't have
that many python workloads in business
intelligence but we do have them in
machine learning so machine learning as
we know is about building machine
learning systems and a machine Learning
System will take your raw data on the
left here we'll be able to create
features from it when we have a feature
store we typically have this particular
architecture um to make up a machine
Learning System we have a feature
pipeline which will take your data it'll
transform it into features and labels we
call that a feature pipeline so it's
input is is data potentially from The
Lakehouse it'll create features and
we'll store them in the feature store
and those features and labels can then
be used to train models so the model
will be stored in a model registry and
then finally we'll have an inference
pipeline which will take a trained model
and some new feature data and make
predictions that could be an online
inference pipeline or a batch inference
Pipeline and what the feature store does
is it gives you access to this data that
we're going to use the feature data and
the labels that we're going to use to
train and make predictions um with it
gives it two apis one is a Lakehouse so
the data is typically stored in a column
or store like a Lakehouse um and that's
the very large volumes of historical
data but the feature store also gives
you very fast access to the latest
feature values for your online
applications and that's often stored in
what we call a row oriented database so
row oriented databases are optimized for
primary key lookups and column or
databases uh like The Lakehouse is
optimized for U queries such as as
workloads such as aggregations and uh
reading large volumes of data at
relatively low cost so um this is where
we have the need for um uh python access
to the to the Lakehouse data because
feature stores typically store their
data their offline data or historical
feature dat data in a lake
house so our python clients will need to
read that data um and if you're going to
train a model and let's say you're using
pyit learn you're probably going to want
to use some client like pandas to read
your data and then train your model in
pyit learn or or or py torch or
tensorflow um and similarly when you're
doing batch inference you may do batch
inference in in py spark but you may
also do batch inference in Python if
you're doing batch inference in Python
you want to be able to read large
volumes of of data from your lake house
so pre-computed features to make
predictions on at quite high
performance so as I mentioned earlier
existing feature stores typically
provide an obbc or jdbc style API to
retrieve that data from the uh tables
that make up uh The Lakehouse so we call
them feature groups the tables that make
up our features and this as we know is a
bottleneck so what we've done in
hopworks is um hops is a feature store
it was the first feature store for
machine learning first open source
feature store I should say and the first
Enterprise feature store um we've worked
at we've seen this problem from from
quite a way back feature stores were
originally spark based
platforms including hopworks which still
supports smark as a query service but
what we did was we built a new feature
query service around duct DB using Arrow
as a transport uh protocol from the the
data stored and The Lakehouse files to
the training pipelines and bch inference
pipelines the clients that read that
data and the very interesting result of
this is of course a huge uh Improvement
in performance effectively what was
previously go grab a cup of coffee or go
grab some lunch before your training
data is ready um has now become an
interactive process you can read
millions of rows of data in
seconds so I'm going to talk about the
Technologies here we've got a Pachi Aro
uh at the start so Pachi Aro is an
in-memory data format it's also an over
the network uh format you can send Arrow
data over the network as the transport
protocol or the me the protocol of
messages that are being sent over the
network it's organized in a columnar uh
layout which is of course optimized for
analytics um so it's it's it it you can
read data from Park files directly into
Apache Aro files with any without any
pivoting of the data from row to column
oriented
format and as such it's also used as an
an an exchange between different
Frameworks so spark has used um P spark
has used arrow for for quite a while so
that EX computers can read in Python can
read data in Arrow um and perform um
udfs and pandas on that
data um without copying the data from
the jvm to python them back and that's
been very efficient for them and we're
now seeing it more widely used within
the py python ecosystem for for example
moving data between pandas polers and
duck DB and there's no need to copy the
data anymore so from pandas 20 arrow is
the backing engine uh for pandas and now
we can do zero copy reads between these
different Frameworks
um so so arrows has huge potential for
um enabling the data to being shared
between different data processing
engines and to be transported
efficiently from The Lakehouse to the
client now there is an existing um RPC
protocol called arlight for defining how
to trans uh transfer our data from a
service uh to
clients and uh we built on this
particular service uh as a way of
transferring data from The Lakehouse so
you have a a server so we developed a
server and that server can read up Arrow
tables from the lake house and transer
uh transfer those Arrow tables to for
example a panda's client that can then
use that data in a training pipeline to
train a
model now uh we didn't do this without
uh doing our research first so um we
looked at some of the benchmarks that
right there and there's some very
interesting ones this is from last year
2022 where they showed a 30X Improvement
uh over jdbc and odbc for reading from
the New York Taxi data set this is done
by
Dro and we can see that that um you know
the here blue is the arrow flight time
taken to read the data from a colmer
format um to to another colmer client so
in the case of obbc they obviously need
to do this pivoting from the columnar to
row oriented and back again but you also
have to serialize your data and
deserialize your data as well which also
costs a lot of CPU time so the you know
this this the the jdbc odbc we can see
visually we're going from this server
where we've got columnar data to the
protocol which is row oriented and back
to the client which is column oriented
and that just takes a lot of CPU time
now particularly with increasing data
volumes um that's becomes less and less
uh practical so I assume we're going to
see lots more of our data warehouse is
moving towards Arrow as a native uh
protocol where clients can read data
directly in Arrow there is actually a
driver now called adbc which is an nrow
um database driver supported by duct DB
um where you can read Arrow data from
clients similar to jdbc so we didn't
build on that we built on arof flight
and we used duct DB is the query engine
now duck DB is a a lightweight in
process uh analytical database
management system you can you can pip
install duct DB in your Jupiter notebook
you can have an ETL pipeline that can
read use duct DB instance to do um data
engineering and what we did is we had an
arlight server using duct TB to perform
the queries on our feature store
now the um these are all possible ways
of using duct TB there are many others
and duct TB um in particular um we uh we
have a particular workload in feature
stores related to creating training data
um which we've seen in spark is quite
challenging so it's called a point in
time correct join it what it means is
basically you have uh you have your
label or or Target data in some table
with time stamps for the observations of
those label data and we want to join in
features from other tables and those
other tables is often time series data
and we want to find the feature value at
the correct point in time now duct DB uh
when we want to perform the uh joins
across many different tables you can see
this join Benchmark released recently by
Duck DB we can see its performance over
spark which was our previous engine is
quite significant from 8 seconds for
this joint Benchmark to 129 seconds in
spark now spark does have a startup time
and so
on um and we did quite lot of work on
spark so we did we've actually changed
the join Implement our own join
algorithm for sparc to improve the
performance of these point in time
correct joins um but still we noticed
that the performance wasn't as good as
we wanted to have an interactive
experience for python developers able to
read this data interactively from the
Lous so what we did was we developed
this service we're calling the hoper
feature query service powered by dub
andar flight and the goals of this
service is to make an easy to use secure
lightweight python client with fast
access to feature store data which is
ultimately stored in leas using in
particular temporal joins so I call this
a point in time correct join it's a
temporal join you're trying to join
uh features from different tables that
are updated at different cadences so
you're not doing an equality join where
you're saying here's the value of my
label at this point in time give me
exactly the features at this point in
time because those time stamps are never
lined up each table will be update its
own cadences so we need to do a temporal
joint we need to find the the closest um
Tim stamp for this feature at this point
in time but earlier we don't want later
otherwise we would have what we call
data
leakage so um this is what the service
looks like we have a client at the top
here and this is python world and we're
trying to interface python World
efficiently with Lakehouse world at the
bottom so lake house world at the bottom
is ultimately going to be our Lakehouse
tables which in our case we're using a
pachy hoodie uh and Park files um as the
The Lakehouse that's stored on S3
ultimately and we have a caching lycal
hopss on top of that so um our service
the Hops hopss feature query service has
dub internally um it's able to read up
the data from the Apache hoodie tables
these paret files as Arrow tables so
duct DB can read up that data natively
and then it might need to um perform
temporal joins across the different
tables and it can do that on the Arrow
data directly and it sends the arrow
data direct back to the client now we
notice that the client here sends a
query in here um I'll show in a minute
that we're not sending SQL as the query
directly so hops works abstracts that
away from you you don't have to write
these complex temporal
joins um and then finally when the DAT
arve arrives at the ARL client with zero
copy it can be imported into the Panda's
data frame now we did a little bit more
work than just this which is the query
service for the native data stored in
hops because hops supports external
tables so you can have as your offline
store big query or snowflake or um red
shift uh which are our data warehouses
so what we added to our external query
service was the ability to join across
um features from for example snowflake
where your labels might be in hops works
and we can do this kind of Federated
query so the way that that works
internally is that um we push the
queries down to the external uh tables
and we retrieve the data as Arrow data
so Arrow tables and then duck DB can
perform the uh joins internally these
temporal joins
internally now dctb is an inprocess um
server so if you run out of memory um
one of the recent versions it will spill
to disk but when it spills to dis
performance will suffer so typically
this service is optimized for queries
that return that fit in memory the
amount of memory you allocate to this
feature query
service um slightly more in spilling to
dis a bit is not too bad but if it's
much larger then you would typically
move to spark so if you um if you were
to create say let's say many tens of
terabytes of training data typically you
would use our Spark engine um but if
you're creating training data on files
that's not necessarily huge maybe it's
only gigabytes um you can do this also
with our uh feature query service so
what duct DB will do is it will create
the for example Park files with training
data and it'll store them on using
whatever connector you use to an S3
bucket or um you know GCS book or hopss
or wherever you're going to store your
training
data so this is the um the query the
temporal join that I talked about for
creating training data it's quite
complex so I have three tables here I
have a table in the top left hand corner
called trip duration and we can see we
have trip seconds as our labels this is
the legend down here at the bottom this
is the thing we're going to try and
predict in a machine learning model and
to do that we need features so I have
the total amount spent um which might be
a useful feature for predicting trip uh
time because if it's I spend more
probably a longer trip and we have trip
miles which may may be available to you
but it's um you know it's it's quite a
good feature um it may not be available
to you beforehand um so you can see
there's a null here um because sometimes
we won't know of course before a trip is
started how long the trip would take um
and then we have um ex the number of
days until your card expires and I'm not
sure if that's a great feature for this
particular model but um it's included
here now there are other columns in here
so our tables have a a primary key um
you can see we also have an event time
column telling us when this feature had
this particular value and we have a
foreign key here pay ID pointing to this
other pay ID column here and credit card
number is another foreign key so the way
in which the training data is created is
it's actually a left join we start at
our label table here and then we join in
features from the trip payment table and
from the payment details tables as
features and we're doing a left join but
it's also Al an as of join so it's going
to take if we take for example Row three
here the 14th of January 2021 it's going
to take the feature value Which is
closest to it but not um later so it's
going to be the closest but um the same
day or or or earlier which is this row
here and this row here has a trip miles
value of null now it's a left joint so
we're still going to include that in our
training date at the
bottom and then we're pulling in another
feature um this is 100 EXP days um using
a nested uh left joint so we're going to
push this down to our database now dub
supports a left as of join which is
great um it means that the SQL to create
this is relatively straightforward and
what we get out of it is our training
data down here we have our three input
features we have our our label column
and it's okay to have a null here
because later on in our training
pipeline or inference pipeline will
impute that value or um we'll set it to
being uh some other value
so um if I'm to do this from if I don't
have a feature store and I want to
create this type of training data from a
data warehouse and this is showing some
code from Big query what you end up is
writing very complex SQL queries and um
the one of the reasons why you end up
writing complex queries this is not a
temporal join by the way in case you're
curious It's just showing a large amount
of SQL and it's embedded as a string in
your python client and and how you
access that data from bigquery for
example is that you pass the string down
it executes it as a job creates a
temporary table and then it reads the
table into a data frame in pandas and
this is the bottleneck you have at the
moment um now the the complex point if
you say well I'm not going to use a
feature store I'm going to write this
code myself because I've only got batch
jobs and then it's pretty
straightforward to do this temporal join
this temporal left
join most data warehouses don't support
left as of joints today they don't
excuse
me um and then you end up writing very
complex um windowed operations which are
extremely challenging to do so if you
don't um want to go this route and and
and write great complex SQL and this is
how you would do write this code in in
hops works so in hops works you would um
log into the feature store we get a
reference to our three different tables
we call them feature groups trip
duration trip payment and payment
details and then we select the features
that we want to include in our in our in
our model so we call we create something
called a feature view this is the
interface of the model the features and
the labels that we have in our
model so we select all of the features
in the first feature group join them
with all the features in the second and
join them with the features in the third
uh feature group and then we create our
feature view with the name taxi and um
the column that we are using as the
Target or label is trip time and this is
our selection of features here so with
this feature view we can easily create
training test data split into our uh
feature feates and our labels uh and
there is data frames and then you can
call model.fit on the uh training set of
lab features and labels and then you can
uh evaluate your model by you know
seeing its performance on the test set
of features so this is ypr and then
compare the performance of the
predictions using the Y test labels
which are the outcomes and the
predictions and then this model you can
register in the model registry such as
hops works so the complexity of writing
all the SQL is kind of hidden for you
but we're pushing it down but most
importantly the performance of this is
is really good so let's have a look at
some of the performance numbers and I
with the provisio that this these
experiments were performed in September
2023 um things are moving very fast in
the space and I expect that the data
warehouses will all support um for uh
Arro data in the near future so these
experiments were performed on the New
York Taxi data set and it's a well-known
data set and what we're trying to do is
is firstly just read training data from
the feature store into Panda's data
frames so that's something that you
commonly would do in a training pipeline
so we have a client over here in panda
is going to read 5 10 20 and 50 million
rows and what we're counting is the
number of rows per second that's read
from our um query engine so here we can
see hopss is is getting somewhere
between two and three million rows per
second um Sage maker is um not doing so
great we can see that you know the
vertex is getting better slightly higher
volumes and data bricks has problems
when you call uh two pandas um we had
difficulties in getting to work at 20
and 50 million rows so um this is the
basically the difference between using
um Arrow as your transport protocol but
also duct DB as our point and time join
engine now we repeated this for creating
training data which is a uh another
thing you might do in your training
pipeline you'll say well I don't want
the data back as as pan as data frames
I'd like to have it as as Park files and
I'll train my model with that and and
again we saw a a large Improvement in
performance um for for for hops Works
compared to the other uh feature stores
and these feature stores are backed by
Sage makers backed by Athena vertexes
big query and data bricks has its own um
Spark
engine so um I can show this briefly we
can have a quick look at this um in
action and hopss I think we have a
couple of minutes so um I I had uh the
Chicago taxi data set it's a slightly
different one to the New York one and I
imported
um4 million rows here um into this this
uh feature group so this is a table of
features we can see there's a bunch of
data there we can get a preview of the
data and this is what it looks like and
and basically I can spin up a notebook
and and start reading that data so one
of the challenges with feature stores
was that it wasn't really interactive
until we uh released a service it would
take take quite a while to to get your
data so here I have a a just I'm logging
into hopworks and I'm going to uh read
some some data from from this taxi
Chicago taxis um feature group um I get
a reference to it I'm just taking
counting the time it takes here um and
it's quite big there's 111 million rows
so I'm not going to read all the data
I'll just read the data after 2022 and
you can see it just said okay you know
reading data in from hopss using arof
flight and this is all running on a
single server I should add
um so this isn't like scaled out to have
a lot of CPUs running out it but I've
read back what's this um yeah just over
1.3 million rows so it's pretty
interactive and it's a nice way of
getting your data quickly um that's it
and with that then um I'd like to
conclude we get a feeling for um the
performance benefits that we get when we
use arlight in particular or Arrow
protocol to transfer data from The
Lakehouse to python clients and we get a
great great boost in terms of this
temporal join with duct DB compared to
using spark and I think what is really
important about this is that if you can
reduce the time it takes for to get data
feature data to data scientists they can
work in a more data Centric AI manner
you can easily do experiments with
different sets of features different
ranges of featured values you can do not
just the random splits I showed you time
series splits and use different ranges
of data and it makes your way of working
more interactive with a feature store
and it makes more natural for python
developers and what this gives you the
ability to think of is that the feature
store can be kind of like a network
drive for your data frames it's easy to
just ingest new data keep writing new
data it manages the incremental data
sets for you and then you can read that
data at Network line speed so it's not
going to slow you down compared to
having to previously maybe store your
data on your laptop and do all your work
there before you go back to the to the
cloud to get uh to do more
work so um that concludes to talk and um
I'd like to um uh thank everyone at this
point and if there are any questions we
can take them in the
chat yeah thanks so much shim that that
was awesome and as as you mentioned
there's nothing in the chat now so if
anyone currently viewing has any
questions we got a three minutes to
cover some of those um so happy to dive
in if
not let's give it a
[Music]
minute
awesome we're waiting for some of those
again just want to say that if anything
does come up or if anything Sparks your
interest we can continue this
conversation in Discord um you'll
actually be able to find a link
available um in the reception area and
then you'll also be able to access this
recording um and I am pretty sure these
recordings come out as soon as the
session is closed uh so if you missed
anything or you want to go back I think
that um for the next next few minutes
you should be able to do so there's a
question from Emily there um just is the
is the code language used in hopster
Python so so hopss has apis there's a
python API um you can also use spark
Flink um and there's a Java API as well
so you can use all those different uh
ways of interacting with the
platform and there's a another question
from Ross popped up I haven't used octb
does it support parallel rights and uh
writes and reads sometimes embedded
databases don't
um it does Ross so there's different
connectors we're using the fs speec
connector there's also an S3 connector
um which does parallel reads so it's um
because again dub is multi-threaded so
python we have this you know um Global
interpreter lock that that you know is a
scalable bottleneck but if you use duct
DB to read it can use as many cores as
you give it and and for example with the
S3 connector it'll read um from
different uh if you have a park uh data
set many files it can read many of those
files in parallel and it makes a huge
difference in terms of
performance and it does that also with
the fs spec uh API that we're using to
help
aest um I will upload the slides into
the Discord um thanks everyone